and Chris one thing that makes it a lot
easier for the Vikings to try to do that
is the fact that they will be operating
not under the rules of the last year of
the prior CBA but the rules of the first
year of the new one that was the
headline from over the weekend late
Saturday into Sunday the voting ended on
the CBA and by mid-morning Sunday we
learned that the players had voted to
ratify the new collective bargaining
agreement by a very narrow margin a
thousand in nineteen yes 959 no sixty
votes was the difference seventy nine
percent turnout it should have been
higher than that given the stakes for
all players still getting eighty percent
nearly four out of five cast a ballot
and Chris I'm convinced after everyone
I've spoken to this thing was dead
before what happened last week and once
the players realized that the world has
changed and the deal on the table would
not be put on the table right now
after the coronavirus situation really
you know caused the public health crisis
created an economic downturn the owners
would not have put that deal on the
table so they grabbed it and it was the
late voting from players who recognized
we got to grab this deal now while we
can that pushed it over the top yeah it
seems that way
first off didn't we better steak dinner
on how close this would be I know I
think I'm like two or three dinners in
the hole but I thought we better bet a
steak dinner on you know how close it
was gonna be and I think I won that book
just to let you know just to remind let
me tell you let me tell you once life
gets back to the point where we can
actually go out and have a steak dinner
I will buy you an entire side of beef
all right sorry Kristen Kristin's got a
bleep ad but hey let's
I can't wait to buy you all the steak
dinners because that will mean that that
a lot of things turned out the right way
yeah yeah I'm with you there I look
forward to those days too but I I do
agree with you and heard the same things
that I think yes the corona scare and
everything that's going on in our world
certainly suede both in the favor of yes
and you know ultimately hey are there
things that I don't love about this new
CBA certainly but as an ex player and
somebody that always seems I know I
always favor the players as you do I
think there was more pauses to get done
from the Players Association standpoint
than negatives and it was never going to
be perfect and I understand some of the
concerns listen
so my ex teammates you know me myself
you know annual medical benefits yeah
they're gonna drop down certainly but
I'm willing to take that I played in the
era where you know there was big money
thrown around and I also realized that
you know guys like my dad teammates in
the 80s and 70s and early nineties are
falling apart and have no medical help
so I'm glad to see them get a little
piece of this pie as well and I'm just
glad a deal came came came about and
we're gonna have football next year and
we can kind of end this knot then yeah
and look I don't know what was gonna
happen if this deal was voted down the
owners very likely may have said we're
not negotiating any further until we can
fully assess the damage to our broader
portfolios from these the kovat 19
crisis and we'll get back to you and of
course anything that they lose elsewhere
they'll try to make back from their
football interest that was the concern
and ultimately at the end of the day the
players lack the ultimate weapon in the
arsenal which is the willingness to take
a work stoppage whether it's a lockout
whether it's a strike we saw at 1987
before many of the players in the NFL
were even born most of the players were
born in 1987 they don't understand the
dynamics Dee Smith did and I think if if
he did anything that wasn't all he
wasn't able to explain to them where
this was gonna end up and that the deal
they have now is as good or better than
the deal they're gonna get later so just
do the deal now and I think it's hard to
explain that to football players I think
that they have their opinions and they
are strong opinions and sometimes logic
and common sense won't get through
because they are used to being very
binary very black-and-white and once
they make up their mind they make up
their minds so it was not easy to get
these guys on the same page enough of
them were on the same page to push this
through and now we have labor peace we
don't know what else
we have but we have labor peace through
2030 and and also Chris one other point
I need to make and you and I've
discussed this before there will be
dramatic relaxation of the marijuana
rules to your chagrin you wish it was
like that when you were in the league
but yeah I saw Josh Gordon's name
trending yesterday on Twitter because
people think he's back in now that's not
how it's gonna work the reinstatement
rules have not changed if you're out you
still have to jump through all the same
hoops to get back in the Commissioner
still has sole discretion to make that
decision there's no requirement under
the policy as to when he has to make
that decision so he's got to dot every I
cross every T and hope that the
commissioner lets him back in and when
he gets back in he's still facing
another banishment because any violation
once you've been reinstated from that
banishment will get you banished again
it's far different from the guys who
aren't suspended the guys who aren't
suspended you can never be suspended for
a positive test for Josh Gordon Chris it
is never going to be that easy and that
applies to Randy Gregory that applies to
David Irving that applies to martavis
Bryant that applies to anyone else who
is currently suspended you are not
automatically getting back in and once
you get back in you much more easily can
be thrown back out than any other player
yeah it's interesting I mean I am glad
to see the relaxed laws or rules as far
as this is concerned I mean yeah you
know my thoughts there first off I mean
come on you know marijuana at this point
we know is about as arbitrary as going
home and drinking a beer or two oh right
which just about everybody doesn't their
profession and then of course you know
with football as brutal as it is it's
physically demanding it is you know many
times I've told you I have teammates who
got you know stuck in need opioids
wormhole because of pain and things like
that and marijuana is a great
replacement for opioid replacements to
make the body feel better that way now
you know as far as the reinstatement
stuff with some of those guys like hey
you know I don't know how I feel about
it I guess to a degree one re for a case
like Josh Gordon you know there's a lot
of things there to where he's had a lot
of issues and he's you know he's said
this himself
to where yeah I do feel like somebody's
got a protectant here when you've had
this many issues go on through your life
and the NFL wants to see him go through
it but you know some of the other guys I
I don't know I guess I feel a little
weird that they have to go through this
whole process and nobody else is gonna
have to go through it you know ever
again really yeah and and look I I think
that they were forgotten in the
negotiation because when I asked D Smith
about it two weeks ago when we
interviewed him he said I have to look
into that get back to I asked him
specifically about the standards that
will apply to the guys who are currently
suspended so I think they just were
overlooked by both sides and now these
guys are going to continue to be in this
weird purgatory where the Commissioner
is the only one who decides whether or
not you can get back in yeah I mean it
seems like that and I would hope that
the NFLPA would argue like hey listen
the guys were it's just strictly
marijuana all right let's let's just let
them back in let's do it
now if there's the guys who have any
other issues to go along with it it may
be more serious drugs all right and
other issues that way then you know I
understand maybe a delay in the
reinstatement and reevaluate because we
got to help these guys out too and as we
know some of these drugs can just be so
addicting that they can overtake human
beings that way so I wish they're just a
purely marijuana guys would just be
allowed in and you know we'll do a
little more research on the guys who
maybe have more severe problems than
that
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports